oh hello i'm gav in this lovely slo-mo
video
we're going to be recreating the effects
of a depth charge
against a submarine and obviously
filming it at insane frame rates
not a real submarine they're quite
expensive so we're going to use a scale
model that fits inside
this here fish tank this video is
sponsored by gopro
for all the slow-mo footage shot from
outside the tank we'll be using phantoms
as normal
but to get shots from inside the tank in
the danger zone
we'll be using the gopro hero 9 black
because it's very rugged and you can get
a waterproof housing for it
we actually had a gopro hero 1 rolling
during our very first shoot
and have used them countless times over
the last 10 years
and we've put them in some pretty
dangerous situations
such as crash bang
hot wear
and up so i'm very thankful that they're
sponsoring this video today why don't we
fill the tank
and get going okay here we have the sub
in the tank for the first experiment
i'm going to be placing a depth charge
just in proximity to the sub see if it
does any damage with
just the shock wave there's an air
bladder inside that might be ruptured
and it's also keeping it buoyant
we will be rolling at 200 frames a
second on this gopro
and i preset all the settings with my
phone
however wi-fi doesn't work through water
so
once we submerge i'll have to frame it
using
the screens built in thankfully there's
one on the front and the back so i can
get the
correct framing that actually looks
pretty epic there looking
straight down the sub so if we put the
depth charge in front of it on this side
we should be able to see if it wobbles
the sub in place
on the outside of the tank i'm going to
be filming this at 28
500 frames a second on a phantom which
means
i'm about to turn on some very bright
lights
okay we're now cooking under the hot
lights
gopro is running at 200 in the tank the
phantom flex 4k is running a thousand
and for the nice tight explosion shot
we're running at 28
500 which should be fast enough but we
may go faster the depth charge is
hanging
just in front in the middle of the sub i
think we're ready to pop it
three two one bang
nice little puff
oh you just see the shock wave bouncing
around off that glass just vibrating
everything
it actually moves insanely fast if i
just put an
arrow that marks the travel of the shock
wave
as it dislodges bubbles you can see how
quickly it moves even dislodging bubbles
from
the gopro housing itself at 28
500 frames a second this is now over a
thousand times
slower than real time whoa just love
that
expansion of gas just carving out
an empty sphere in the middle of the
water you can see that the way the
charge
separated we actually lost a lot of
energy there
because the bottom sort of shot off the
pressure of the surrounding wall now
closed that back up which means that not
only is there a shock wave traveling
around that tank from the original
explosion
the moment it all slams closed it will
release another shock wave which will
bounce around in there
just vibrating every single joint of
this submarine
it even popped open the little escape
edge love it
okay so now we're going to more tightly
wrap that charge and hopefully give us
a bit more punch by wasting less energy
downwards
for those curious as to why i'm blasting
this with so much light you may remember
from the original underwater video
in order to get any detail in the
explosion itself i had to stop the lens
down so much that
everything else was almost pitch black
and i wanted to capture detail inside
the explosion as well as
the submarine itself so by hitting it
with much more light i can stop the
lenses down
so that the explosions aren't just pure
white and the submarine is in
pure darkness i'm now slightly closer on
both cameras
just to really see the the meat of the
explosion
center it up there okay
here we go
three two one bang
blew the top off but
the air bladder still intact very
interesting one
oh i saw some great frames in there i
think i saw the thumbnail
let me find let me see the thumbnail
frame
[Music]
yeah i think that's the one i think
that's the thumbnail
oh yeah it's just through the entire
look at those vortices
it's because it threw the entire
explosion forwards into the glass
it's always just so interesting to see
explosions at such a
leisurely pace you can see it's thrown
the front of that out of focus just
because it came so far forwards
and here you can see the granules the
the powder from the new explosion
actually
moving with such velocity they've
escaped the original
explosion sphere and now they're being
sucked back in as it all implodes and
shoots forwards just an absolutely
devastating effect on all the joints of
the sub
we're only about a foot under water here
but the camera is actually waterproof
out of the box
to 33 feet that depth charge looked
great however i really want to bust the
air bladder inside
so we're going to do now same depth
charge in the same place
however there are now three charges on
the top to hopefully blow the top of the
sub open
and there's one on the inside so that
the bag definitely breaks so we should
see a nice
bubble of air and maybe it will sink i
now have a second
gopro mounted on the bottom this one is
recording in 4k
not slo-mo just to get the sub sinking
if it does sync
this one still rolling in slow-mo 200
frames a second
is now mounted to the sub itself and
mounted
extremely close to the charges should
get some lovely footage but we'll
probably go flying
thankfully because it's such a rugged
camera the footage will be saved
in theory three two one bang
whoa
can't wait to see the footage on that
where's the gopro landed
oh yeah it okay it flew off but
let me see if i can see if it's rolling
i still see a flashing red light
that's very good news
oh those charges on top were meaty
just sent a shock wave all the way down
the end snapping the
sub at its rear joint and the fact that
you can see the surface of the water
really shows you how much that glass is
wobbling back and forth
whoa so the the big charges on top went
off before the
depth charge on the side you can see
tiny cavitation bubbles
working their way from right to left as
it travels just
tearing up that plastic of the sub speed
it up and back and forth that you can
see it's travel
i also shot a lovely bubble ring from
that hole
directly below the charge so the air
bladder inside definitely popped but it
the shock waves are just bouncing the
air around inside
and the depth charge there it must have
been waterlogged because
it pretty much just coughed instead of
its usual explosion
gopro's still on there oh there he goes
yeah the air took a long time to come
out just because
the shock waves were bouncing it around
inside sending some of it down some of
it left and right
mental now let's see if the gopro saw
anything useful before it was chucked
oh yeah oh yeah we saw some good frames
there no
issues with the footage a lot of times
that i've put cameras near
massive shockwaves like that you will
get artifacts and glitches
but i didn't see an issue with any of
those frames there
that's the other one landing that shock
wave was so powerful it actually
jumped the very heavy metal bar keeping
the subway down
well there we have it some lovely
looking footage and as expected the
gopros got chucked all over the place
especially the ones i mounted to the
submarine itself but they all survived
got the footage off all of them and uh
did a damn good job in my opinion
if you care about my opinion on this
camera the things i like about it
over the previous versions is mainly
this clip i'm not sure when this started
my previous gopro
you need an external housing to mount it
to stuff i love that it's built into the
camera body now
and the front screen is great when you
can't get around the back of the camera
if you want a hero 9 black of your own
go to gopro.com
slow-mo guys big old thanks to gopro for
sponsoring this video even bigger thanks
to you
for watching it if you like slow-mo in
general make sure you subscribe
and i'll see you in the next video thank
you very much for watching